[Music]
from the studio
that's a conjuring away from making all
the horror movies comes a film that at
first glance looks like a slasher
version of Groundhog Day
but then in a surprise twist is happy
deathday tree gilman is having the worst
birthday ever
the kind that starts with waking up next
to this goober oh hey and Ed's with
being murdered by a psycho in a baby
mask that you'll have to relive over and
over again until she discovers who the
killer is and stops being such an a-hole
how does it all fit on those two and
makes peace with her estranged father
you big day tree gilman is having the
worst birthday ever
the kind that starts with waking up next
to this goober okay and ends with being
murdered by a psycho in a baby mask that
you'll have to relive over and over
again until huh I feel like I've done
this part before then we play some clips
of her being mean how does it only last
week
oh crap I've Groundhog Day myself the
edge of tomorrow my self I mean happy
death date myself what did I say last
time here big day no no tree gilman is
having the worst birthday ever
goober underclassmen okay let's do the
baby mask same scenes over and over okay
focus you can figure this out maybe
talking about the characters will help
and she'll break out with some help from
Carter who clears the world's lowest bar
to become her drink guy I didn't take
advantage in last night okay
together they'll help tree becomes
slightly less awful than her sorority
sister which time are you going to yep I
see
learn to let loose
and solve the mystery of who's trying to
kill her or I guess just survive into
the next day did I get it right
okay please work please work please work
tree gilman is having the worst ohh
she wakes up next to the heroic non
rapist Carter oh hey and has to unmask
this baby face or get another pg-13
friendly death and she better do it
quick because while this villain may
look like a baby
he moves like a really fast baby him a
slasher with cardio loss really is
revolutionising horror boom nailed it
treed Gelman son of a [ __ ] okay let's
be rational about this she had to become
less of an a-hole to escape so maybe I
have to be less mean to well fine I'll
say it I liked this film all right look
the setup isn't original
but overall it's fun and Jessica Roth is
great okay so if you like entertaining
slasher films that don't take themselves
too seriously
with enough twists to keep you guessing
maybe check out happy deathday there set
it up for you
I'll even point out how the dorm room is
the right size when's the last time you
saw an appropriately sized dorm room in
a movie huh are we good are we good
starring yes we made it make like a tree
and be
nice guys finish past Regina George
Brett Kavanaugh Cupcake Wars and Tommy
pickles loop her welcome to The Pleasure
Dome whoa
can this guy have a dance-off with army
hammer and Oscar Isaac we all boo boo
some people move on but not us not us
mama made me mash my M&Ms popcorn
chicken vibes soaring scoob's maroon 5 -
spongebob
now they roll